>> Dana: I HAVE HEARD OF ELVIS
PRESLEY.
>> Greg: IN AN ARTICLE
PUBLISHED IN "U.S. NEWS &
WORLD REPORT" WHERE IT'S SHOWN
HOW GOVERNMENT CAN MAKE ALMOST
ANYTHING WORSE, IN THE WAKE OF
THE OPIOID CRACKDOWN, THE CDC
HAS HAD PAINKILLER SHOULD BE A
LAST RESORT FOR PATIENTS.
THE RESULT: MEDICAL SOCIETIES
GREATLY REDUCED PRESCRIPTIONS,
INSURERS REFUSE TO COVER THEM
FOR PATIENTS WITH CANCER OR
SICKLE CELL ANEMIA.
EVEN WHEN PATIENTS WEREN'T
DENIED COVERAGE, THEY HAD TO
JUMP THROUGH MORE HOOPS THAN
DOLPHINS AT SEAWORLD.
THERE IS NO DENYING WE HAVE GOT
IT ALL.
PROBLEM BUT TO MAKE IT WORSE
WITH BROAD STROKES BASED ON FEAR
AND MISINFORMATION.
THE PROBLEM IS AND PRESCRIPTION
OPIOIDS.
BUT STREET FENTANYL.
THE ADDICTION RATE FOR
PRESCRIPTIONS IS LOW.
THE OVERDOSES FROM STREET DRUGS
ARE NOT.
TARGETING THE PRESCRIPTION SIDE
HARMS CANCER PATIENTS AS WELL AS
OTHER PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC AND
ACUTE PAIN.
AS THE MEDIA FRAMES IT AS AN
EPIDEMIC, WHAT YOU GET IS THE
SAME OLD ONE SIDE CRUSHES ALL
REACTION THAT SMACKS EVERY FLY
WITH A HAMMER.
IF YOU'RE A CONSERVATIVE AND
DISAGREE, CONSIDER FIREARMS.
SHOULD YOU PUNISH LAWFUL GUN
OWNERS FOR THE CRIMES OF STREET
GANGS ARMED WITH ILLEGAL
WEAPONS?
KNOW, THAT WOULD BE A VIOLATION
OF YOUR RIGHTS.
WHY SUSPEND THAT LOGIC HERE?
THE PROBLEM WITH OPIOIDS IS THAT
THEY WORK.
THE WORST THING YOU CAN DO IS
LET THE GOVERNMENT TRANSFER
BUSINESS TO THE DRUG DEALER WHO
IS MORE THAN HAPPY TO OBLIGE.
DANA, THE GOOD NEWS HERE IS THAT
THE CDC IS ACTUALLY KIND OF
CHANGING THEIR STORY AND SAY NOW
YOU CAN PRESCRIBE THEM FOR
CERTAIN THINGS.
THEY ARE KIND OF LOOSENING THE
REINS.
>> Dana: THEY OVERREACTED TO A
PROBLEM.
PEOPLE WERE WORRIED.
TO THE BAD ACTORS, THERE WERE
SOME, PUSHING OUT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PILLS TO ONE LITTLE
TOWN.
FAKE PRESCRIPTIONS, ALL OF THAT.
AS YOU SAID, THE GOVERNMENT
MESSES THINGS UP, RIGHT?
I HAVE AN IDEA.
LET'S HAVE IT TAKE OVER ALL OF
OUR HEALTH CARE.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
>> Dana: THAT'S THE THING I
DON'T UNDERSTAND OF THE WHOLE
MEDICARE FOR ALL PEACE BUT WE
WILL FIND OUT AS HE DOES HIS
TOWN HALL WITH US ON MONDAY.
I ALSO THINK WHEN YOU HAVE
GOVERNMENT OVERREACTION TO A
PROBLEM, YOU SEE IT OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
IT'S ABOUT TO HAPPEN IN THE TECH
SECTOR.
GOVERNMENT IS ALWAYS BEHIND ON
INNOVATIONS, TECHNOLOGY, AND
TRYING TO MAKE UP FOR LOST TIME
AND THEY END UP SCREWING THINGS
UP.
>> Greg: EMILY, DURING
PROHIBITION, THERE WERE A LOT OF
DEATHS ATTRIBUTED TO BATHTUB GIN
BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T BUY IT IN
THE STORE.
YOU HAD TO MAKE IT.
TEN CASES HAPPENING WITH
OPIOIDS.
PEOPLE END UP WITH STREET DRUGS
AND THEY DIE.
ISN'T IT BETTER TO HAVE
PRESCRIPTIONS WHERE THEY CAN BE
MODULATED AND MODERATED?
>> Emily: YES.
ALSO I WANT VIEWERS TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR RIGHT AND A
RASH OF LAWSUITS THAT HAS COME
TO CONCLUSIONS.
A LARGE AMOUNT OF SETTLEMENTS.
FOR EXAMPLE, I WANT TO USE
OKLAHOMA AS A CASE STUDY FOR
VIEWERS TO UNDERSTAND.
$270 MILLION SETTLEMENT, ALL OF
THE MONIES, PRIVATE MONEY FROM
DRUGMAKERS WHO DID NOT ADMIT
LIABILITY.
IT'S GOING TO STATE INSTITUTION
INSTITUTIONS.
THAT IS ALL STAYING WITHIN THE
STATE OF OKLAHOMA.
WHO DO YOU THINK IS GOING TO
FUND THIS AFTER THE INITIAL
270 MILLION GOES TO ESTABLISHING
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR DRUG
ADDICTION TREATMENT AND
PROVIDING THOSE MEDICINES.
TAXPAYERS WILL ASSUME THAT DEBT
AFTERWARDS OBVIOUSLY.
AS YOU'LL I'M SURE REMEMBER
AFTER THE BIG TOBACCO FIASCO IN
THE LATE '90s, THERE WAS A
HUGE, THE DEBACLE WAS WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THE MONEY
MISMANAGEMENT AFTER MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN PAYMENTS AND
SETTLEMENTS PLAYED OUT.
EVERYONE SHOULD KEEP TRACK AND
NOTE WHAT IS OCCURRING WITH THE
SETTLEMENTS AND WHAT HAPPENS AND
WHO CARRIES THE BILL MOVING
FORWARD.
>> Greg: THERE HAS BEEN SOME
PROGRESS, JUAN, IN THE SENSE
THAT I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP
CONVINCED CHINA TOOK CRACKDOWN
ON THE CHINESE FENTANYL AND THE
DRUG DEALERS.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE BEING
PUNISHED BY DEATH THAT THEY ARE
ARRESTED.
IN CHINA, IT'S POSSIBLE.
>> Juan: IN AGREEMENT WITH YOU
BUT I THINK WHERE WE PART
COMPANY AS I THINK A LOT OF
DOCTORS, I THINK THE
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES PUSHED
LEGAL OPIOIDS AT A HIGHER RATE
AND FOR SOME COMMUNITIES,
ESPECIALLY POOR COMMUNITIES,
TRAGIC CONSEQUENCES.
WHEN WE HEAR ABOUT SETTLEMENTS,
EVEN IF THEY DON'T ADMIT
LIABILITY, THE REASON FOR THE
SETTLEMENT IS THAT THEY KNOW
THEY COULD GET HIT EVEN HARDER.
WE HAD PAIN MANAGEMENT BEFORE WE
HAD OPIOIDS.
THERE'S OTHER WAYS TO DEAL WITH
PAIN.
BUT I THINK IF WE PULL BACK AND
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT, PEOPLE SHOULD
HAVE TOTAL ACCESS TO OPIOIDS.
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND THE DOCTORS
IN FACT ARE PART OF THE PROBLEM.
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
MANUFACTURERS.
>> Greg: GOVERNMENT DOESN'T
KNOW MORE THAN DOCTORS.
>> Juan: WE CAN TALK ABOUT
ABORTION ON THAT FRONT THAT I
AGREE WITH YOU.
I DO THINK THAT WHEN GOVERNMENT
SEES THAT THE PEOPLE ARE BEING
HURT AND WE DO HAVE HIGH RATES
OF DEATHS TIED TO THIS, BOTH
THOSE STREETS AND BEFORE THAT --
>> Greg: THEY HAVE BEEN VERY,
VERY INACCURATE ON THAT CURE
OPIOID OVERDOSES.
THE RATE OF ADDICTION FROM
PEOPLE WHO USE OPIOIDS IS SO
SMALL.
THE TWO MAJOR STUDIES THAT I'VE
READ SHOW IT'S 1%.
>> Jesse: TELL ME MORE ABOUT
THIS BATHTUB GIN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: THAT'S WHAT GOT YOU?
>> Greg: IT'S A GREAT ANALOGY
THAT IF YOU MAKE SOMETHING
ILLEGAL, PEOPLE WILL JUST FLOCK
TO THE ILLEGAL.
I'M SURE THAT'S NEVER HAPPENED
YOU, JESSE.
>> Jesse: NO, NEVER HAPPENED
TO ME.
GREG, PEOPLE SAY ABOUT YOU,
YOU'RE ON THE TRUMP TRAIN,
DRIVING THE TRUMP TRAIN.
JUDY CHU.
NOT ON THIS.
YOU'RE FIGHTING AGAINST THE
TRUMP WAR ON OPIOIDS.
>> Greg: I THINK HE'S BEING
CYNICAL.
>> Dana: I THINK HE'S BEING